Okay, so let's go into it. 6 minute 21
second mark. You asked for it. You want
me to do this, right?
You sure you want me to do this?
We'll see how much we can get into cuz I
know there are a couple of prompts.
Prompt one is on the Trinity.
All right.
It is God or logic. It's lady logic.
Familiar with him and the Nicene Creed,
there was a council of men, right? And
Constantine, let's talk a little bit
about his history. Constantine was
originally a pagan worshiper and then he
converted to Christianity because the
Roman Empire at the time, it needed
strength. But the Romans were sun god
worshipers. And so he knew after he
accepted Christianity, that he would
have to
enter a mix paganism with Christianity
in order for Rome to take Christianity
as the religion.
>> Wait, so you're telling me
Constan-
Constantine
a pagan, he had to then corrupt
Christianity by introducing paganism.
Isn't it ironic? That's actually Islam
in a nutshell. If you guys don't know,
the Muslims will admit to you
that the pagan Arabs
in
Arabia and Mecca and Medina,
they worshiped Allah as the high God
and they worshiped gods and goddesses
along with Allah.
And the Muslim sources say that at the
Kaaba, there was 360 idols.
And that the Muslim sources attest that
Hubal or Hubble was the chief god of
Mecca, the chief god of Muhammad's
parents,
right? And his grandparents.
And that there was an idol of Hubble,
Hubal, and that Muhammad's grandfather,
he would go to that idol, that statue of
Hubble or Hubal, some pronounce it
Hubble.
And as he's praying to Allah, he would
face that statue.
And that they would circum-
circumambulate the Kaaba seven times,
run around it seven times. They would
run between the two hills of Safa and
Marwah seven times.
Then they would throw seven stones at
Wadi Mina.
And according to the Muslim sources,
these pagans were into fertility astral
worship. Let me explain this. You guys
want me to go into a little meat, right?
Pray again, Holy Spirit perfects my
recall of facts.
Let me explain what I mean. And I have a
document. I have the articles. Yusuf Ali
and others.
And go watch my series and playlists.
See, the cat won't leave me alone, see?
See, watch here, watch. So, you can see
I'm not lying.
I watch the cat. Watch, see? It's going
to go around. Watch here. See? What I
tell you?
See that little cat?
Now, watch here.
According to the sources, and I'll I If
you want, I'll show you the links where
you can find them.
According to the sources,
right?
>> [clears throat]
>> The pagans
were into astral worship, as almost
every pagan was. Listen and learn. I
want to go in depth for your benefit.
And they were into also what they call
fertility
cult.
If you trace paganism,
you will see the belief among them, and
I'll probably sit on the couch.
That the gods, goddesses affected the
crops and the seasons.
Now, ironically, there's some truth in
that. What do I mean? If you followed my
sessions and you followed my
discussions, I've shown you from
scripture, like Revelation 7:1-3 and
Revelation 9:18-23,
that spirit powers, spirit creatures,
both righteous and evil,
have been endowed with powers and
abilities by God
to affect
ecology,
affect seasons,
right? They can affect the sun.
They can affect the waters. They can
affect the earth's crust. They can cause
tsunamis. They can cause earthquakes. I
gave you the receipts. Go watch the
series, especially when I went into the
book of Job.
So, ironically, there is some truth that
the spirit creatures manipulate the
natural realm, the material realm.
They can affect your crops.
So, the pagans saw this and knew this
that their gods were actually demons,
had powers and abilities they don't
have, which the Bible confirms they do.
Job 1, Job 2, Revelation 7, Revelation
9, Revelation 16. I've given you
receipts.
Right?
But, they also believed
that the planets were identified and
associated with these gods and
goddesses, which is also confirmed in
the Bible. Did you know that?
The Bible confirms that the pagans
looked to the sun, and moon, and stars
as planetary deities, meaning
these planets
were identified, associated with gods
and goddesses.
So, it's not so much that the planet is
a god
in so far that they knew that deity
could appear in visible form like a
human,
but that the planet was identified,
associated with that god or goddess. You
guys know this? These facts?
Let's go into me.
Right?
You hear me there?
Let's go into me.
So, according to the Muslim sources, and
let me show you the documentation.
The Arabs believed the moon god was the
male deity. So, they had gods and
goddesses. So, in these cultures, if you
are patriarchal
patriarchal
meaning you believe the male is the head
then you will associate
the chief god
with
>> [clears throat]
>> maleness
as a male masculinity
So, here's what's interesting
that the Arabic word for moon, qamar
is masculine.
So, the Arabs looked to the moon as the
chief god, the male god.
The word for sun, shams [snorts]
is feminine. So, the sun was known as
the wife, the consort of the moon.
So, the moon was the chief god cuz the
moon represent the male. So, it's
identified with the chief god. Now, if
the chief god is Allah
that means the moon was associated with
Allah.
See how that works? So, Yusuf Ali will
admit here, I'll show it to you. So,
let's keep the timestamp 6 minutes 52
seconds. You see how in-depth I got to
go when I discuss this?
If you go right here, I'll show you
where to find it.
Yusuf Ali admits
that the pagan Arabs would run around
the Kaaba seven times for the seven
planets identified with their gods and
goddesses.
Okay?
The pre The identity of pre-Islamic
Allah.
Ready?
You guys are bored out with these
details or you're okay with it that I
take some time and unpack all this
stuff.
Well, no, they don't say that now,
brother. Don't misrepresent them.
Cuz you're taking the story of
Abraham, but then he says, "Neither the
sun nor the moon nor the morning star,
Venus,
is his ilah."
Okay?
You guys mind if I go through this?
It's up to you guys.
I'm doing it for you to see the irony.
The irony that a Muslim would talk about
paganism and Christianity. Here it is.
Abdullah Yusuf Ali.
To revert to the worship of the heavenly
bodies, a few individual stars did
attract the worshipers. That's not about
the pagan
ism of the Arabs
according to Muslim sources.
Sirius, the dog star, brightest fixed
star in the heavens,
with the bluish tinge in its light.
It is probably Sirius that is referred
to as a fixed star in the parable of
Abraham, chapter 6:76. Now watch. With
regard to the fixed stars in their
myriads, the astronomers turned their
fancy to devising groups or
constellations.
But the moving stars or planets, each
with a motion therefore,
will or influence of its own. So, the
planets would affect you, the motion.
But the moving stars or planets, each
with a motion and therefore will have
or influence of its own. As they knew
and understood them, there were seven in
number.
Seven in number.
So, the pagans thought there were only
seven planets. They counted sun and moon
as two.
Right?
One and two, the moon and the sun.
The two objects that most closely and
and
dubitably influence the tides, the
temperatures, the life in our planet.
Three and four, the two inner planets,
Mercury and Venus,
which are morning and evening stars and
ever travel far from the sun.
Five, six, and seven, Mars, Jupiter, and
Saturn.
So, the number seven itself is a mystic
number.
It will be noticed the sun and moon and
the five planets God identified each
with a living deity, God
or goddess
with the characters and qualities
qualities of its own.
See it?
You see that?
Now, why did they view the moon as a
chief God? Because the Arabic word for
the moon, qamar, is masculine gender.
And they're patriarchal. Sun Shams is
feminine.
Now, do you see why the Muslims run
around the Kaaba seven times?
Yep, Drake.
Do you now have the answer?
So, it's ironic that Muslims are going
to tell us Christianity was corrupted by
paganism when their entire religious
system, their rites is from paganism.
So, how do they explain it away?
How do they explain away? They'll say,
"No, stupid kafir.
Don't you know that Abraham
went there to Mecca when Ishmael settled
there
and that Abraham and Ishmael built the
Kaaba and Allah told Abraham and Ishmael
about these rites to run around seven
times
and then the descendants of Ishmael
corrupted those rites and paganized
them, so Muhammad is restoring them?"
Now, who believes that?
Does anyone believe that story?
You tell them, "What proof do you have
pre-Islamic sources
that Ishmael settled in Mecca,
Abraham visited Ishmael, built the Kaaba
and instituted these rites?"
What
pre-Islamic archaeological
textual proofs do you have
besides later Muslim sources that aren't
even contemporary with Muhammad
that Ishmael ever settled there?
Right?
In point of fact, there is no historian
scholar that takes that seriously. Do
you know why? Because most of the
historian scholars don't even believe
that Abraham existed.
You with me there?
>> [snorts]
>> They don't even believe Genesis.
They think that Abraham, Isaac, and
Jacob, they're fictional
persons. They're not historical.
That simply what you have in the Torah
is a
romanticized [clears throat]
fanciful
>> [clears throat]
>> mythical
story of etiology. These people don't
exist.
So, is that not ironic?
You're going to
talk about paganism and Christianity?
You got to be kidding me.
Anyway, let's go back.